disgraced former rnb singer r kelly has
been sentenced to 30 years in prison for
leading a decades-long sex trafficking
operation kelly appeared in federal
court in brooklyn yesterday where
survivors of his abuse gave very
emotional accounts of their pain and
their suffering over the years national
correspondent jerica duncan spoke with
two of those survivors and she has more
on the sentencing and its impact
no amount of money or fame is enough to
evade justice
that was the message from federal
prosecutors after r kelly was sentenced
to three decades behind bars following
his conviction of sex trafficking
charges last september
seven survivors addressed the court
wednesday one said kelly made her his
sex slave another described how he
deprived her food as punishment and one
woman recounted the time kelly forced
her to perform oral sex on him when she
was underage adding that his abuse made
her wish she would die
kelly did not make eye contact with any
of the survivors some demanded he do so
as they read their impact statements the
55-year-old has long denied the
allegations against him robert i didn't
do this stuff
including in this exchange with gail
king in 2019
he never thought
that his victims
would ever dare to speak out against him
attorney gloria allred represents
several survivors of kelly's alleged
sexual abuse including javonte
cunningham she was friends with the late
singer aaliyah and testified that she
witnessed kelly in a sexual act with the
young music star when aaliyah was
underage nobody ever listened they said
we were lying we were making it up we
just wanted to be famous we were looking
for some money you were quiet for so
long
and now you're kind of like one of the
voices of
this group of women being silent
afforded him the ability to do this over
and over again
i had to speak for leah i had to speak
for those who were not strong enough to
speak for themselves and i had to speak
for myself we spoke to another survivor
who testified who did not want to reveal
her identity she asked that we call her
sonja everything that happened to me
there
had made me feel like i was scum of the
earth it's really hard to come back from
that
but you did
trying
r kelly's new attorney jennifer bondine
who represented bill cosby plans to
appeal wednesday's sentencing which also
includes five years of supervised
release and a 100 thousand dollar fine
kelly is still facing child pornography
enticement of a minor in obstruction of
justice charges in chicago that trial is
scheduled to begin in august and you
know gail you and i we've been literally
covering this story a long time and um
one of the survivors asked me you know
well what do you think about it and i
said it was so interesting to see how
polarizing this has been because there
were people outside of the courthouse
yelling and screaming in support of him
and calling the women liars and he still
has he's fighting the audio that was
played in court despite the video that
was shared and the testimony of 45
witnesses he still has a lot of support
and i reach out to a couple of survivors
too because i know this can be very
triggering and they said finally they
believe justice has been served and that
they were heard and believed right
that's the thing that they were believed
and they were all hoping that he would
say something seems like a closing of
the chapter of his career and hopefully
some closure for the women tarika thank
you